I do I do but I heard from my doctor
that now they're coming out with a blood
test that can detect cancer cells and
pretty accurately tell you where it may
be in your body have you heard of that I
heard some preliminary stuff nothing
usable right now
right now it's still future
okay like that's for everything whether
or not someone's pitching you a whole
body scan to find cancers early I'm not
a fan of any of this stuff you're not a
fan of a body scan because a lot of
people are going for that body scan a
lot of people are talking about it and
and I I hear people who said they went
for the body scan and they were able to
detect something early where they had no
symptoms and they saw something and
caught it why why are you anti-scan okay
so this is a pretty dense conversation
because you can get into a lot of
nitty-gritty here but let's just take it
on its face value when we recommend
doing like let's get CAT scan out of it
because CAT scan has radiation that's
very obviously bad to constantly radiate
people but like let's talk about MRI
body scans there's actually indications
where if a patient has specific genetic
conditions that they have really high
risk for cancer we do recommend MRI body
scans but for the average healthy person
that doesn't have those conditions
scanning things does not yield better
outcomes and a lot of times you'll also
also always find some lump bump or thing
that has of no significance that then
you're going to have to pursue and
either scan again every six months or go
in and biopsy and now risk having a side
effect from the biopsy and downstream
medical effects where just scanning and
letting it be like just not scanning and
letting it beat would be the better
choice so again when we make our
recommendations it comes from the fact
that if I know I scan you know a million
people that more people are going to
benefit from this than get harmed I
don't have that data from MRI body scans
I have that for people who are
hereditary high risk of cancer there's
specific conditions where people have
really high risks of cancer and those
people we do MRI by accident I like the
way you I liked it just the way you
operate probably in life and
professionally because you're not um
I think that people are kind of um drawn
toward uh the um alarmist because that's
kind of louder
and more noticeable and I like a doctor
who is anti-alarm can I ask you a
question as a parent no questions
my kids to like their yearly annual
checkups and stuff why don't they do
blood tests for kids like their yearly
annual checkups to make sure
everything's good uh well the idea of
doing blood tests just to see if
everything's good does not work
we don't have all the answers by doing
all the blood tests we do not like so
you're asking why don't they screen for
conditions yes if you're going every I
mean it doesn't make sense to me that I
go in and they look and they make them
cough and like look in their throat and
they're like all right you're good for
another year like what was
it seems like a pediatrician just
basically gives you your place on your
chart they weigh you if they don't see
anything it doesn't seem like we're
doing anything blood work sometimes
there are indications for some blood
work for screening for example if I have
a 10 year old come in and they have a
very strong history of high
triglycerides that run in the family or
high cholesterol that runs in the family
early heart disease I'll I'll check them
with the lipid profile to see if they
have uh familial hypercholesterolemia
which is a condition where they have
really high cholesterol and they can
have a heart attack in their 40s so we
do check in some cases there's also
times where we check hemoglobin or
hematocrit lead levels there's like all
instances where we do check but on
average there's no value to just check a
healthy person because if you have a
child who's anemic let's say they will
show symptoms of anemia right so the
idea of checking average healthy people
that's called screening and there are
some instances where we do screening pap
smear screening colonoscopy screening
we're taking everyone no matter what
they're they're like whether or not they
have symptoms or not that's screening we
do blood tests also for diagnosis where
you have a symptom like you're fatigued
you're tired you look pale now I'm going
to give you a blood test to diagnose you
with anemia that is no longer screening
so you're talking about screening and we
do not see the value in screening
healthy people for most blood tests
especially kids
answer your question yeah I have one
other question and also those blood
tests a lot of times you're here we'll
come up with some things that are like
slightly off because they happen to be
that day that they're off and now we're
doing another whole investigation where
your child again has no symptoms and
there's no better example of this with
thyroid levels for some reason some of
my residents that I train young doctors
they'll like get a thyroid level on
patients and I'm like why'd you get a
thyroid level like Oh I thought it was a
normal lab I should get on everybody so
they have a healthy person they check
their thyroid level it's slightly off
should I give them thyroid hormone now
but the patient's fine so but what you
should do and correct me if I'm wrong
then you should follow up and have them
take another thyroid level that's a good
that's a good idea you check it again
and it's again low
okay so do we treat the person I don't
know I'm not a doctor well why are you
asking logic wise forget the doctor
thing you don't need a degree for this
hypothetical so but I don't know
logically speaking they have low thyroid
on the test it makes you should treat
that's what people do they're like oh
your level's low here's the treat and
now you have symptoms of hyperthyroidism
and now you have palpitations you're
anxious and it's my fault that I gave
you the thyroid you are fine but now I'm
treating the lab value not the patient
you treat the patient not the lab value
makes sense
wow you're smart
[Music]
foreign